hello everyone and welcome to another
incredible game from the final round of
this year's Tata still Masters Edition
now that we know that Anish won his game
against 300 Rapport there is only one
man who can take first place from Anish
and that is not Rebecca dusatrov who
went into the final round uh with a uh
with a half a point lead ahead of Anish
yiri and the full point ahead of Magnus
Carlson and Wesley so so by a niche
winning that means that uh it doesn't
matter if if Wesley or Magnus win their
games they can no longer win the
tournament the butt and Order back can
so let's see what happened uh in his
game against the
um well Jordan Farm Forest so uh another
back with the white pieces opens with E4
we have Pawn to C5 uh Jordan goes for
the Sicilian Defense Knight F3 we have
E6 and now Pawn to D4 we have characters
captures so uh accepting the the Central
Pawn Knight the C6 Knight to C3 and
queen to C7 the bastrical variation of
the taimanov uh Bishop to E3 and now
upon the A6 with Queen to F3 and another
big playing a a very uh the well just
developing his pieces very nicely and
now usually you will see Knight to F6
here or maybe bishop to D6 or even
Knight to E5 but here Jordan goes for
Ponte H5 it's not a new move but it is
an extremely rare one we have Queen side
castles just going for super rapid
development here and now uh there is a
game where Knight the E5 and Knight to
F6 were played but here we have Ponte a
B5 Now by Jordan and it is now as of
move eight that we have a completely new
game and this is definitely not the kind
of game uh Abdus Auto wants to play in
the final round where he needs at least
a draw
at uh to go into tie breaks against
Anish giri now still with a win uh he
wins the entire tournament and this is
by no means bad for white is actually a
very good position for white it's just
that it's a very rare move eight in the
in in the Sicilian already a completely
new game uh well now you just have to
play chess uh so Queen to G3 he goes for
a queen trade right away and Jordan
accepts captors captures and now Bishop
the C5 puts pressure on the Knight here
we have Pawn to G4 now makes sense as
the rook and h8 is undefended and now
Bishop to B7 you could play uh Pawn to
H4 uh but after G3 it seems like white
is just gonna win this Pawn there's the
very tricky G5 and it's not not so clear
you can't really capture that pawn as
the bishop is essential in the defense
of the Knight and D4 so here things
would get incredibly complicated but
Jordan doesn't go for that he just goes
for Bishop to B7 and now uh he's
basically uh offering the H5 Pawn G
captures an H5 another bit can undouble
get uh get a nice Pawn here but he
doesn't instead he plays Spawn to F3 and
here already you can sense that another
back is maybe not playing for a win he's
actually just playing not to lose uh
Pawn to G6 and now Knight the F5 looks
uh looks like like a wild move but in
fact just trading pieces as the bishop
and C5 is also hanging so Bishop
captures an E3 with check Knight
captures and King the E7
uh Jordan now gets his King to a nice
Central Square and now the Rooks can
come into the game with the chapter E2
Now Pawn to D6 we have Pawn to G5
grabbing more space on the king side and
pawn to F6 Jordan once the uh get
through that pawn to F for G captures
and F5 F captures and G5 and now Knight
to E5 uh now the the idea behind Knight
the E5 is that the bishop is now
attacking the E4 pawn and okay the
Knight is defending it but you will play
B4 on the next small kick away the
Knight and just win the E4 Pawn so
another big defends it Rook to D4 and
now Rook the d8 just nicely continuing
development and now Rook H the D1 uh by
another back again not really uh trying
to to play for the win here A4 is the
move you always play once you see this
A6 B5 setup you always play A4 uh unless
okay you you have too much stuff on the
board the Queens are on the board it's
some sort of a position where you can
get checkmated this is what you want to
play our point is that afterlits and
Knight C6 attacks The Rook Rook D2 or D1
doesn't really matter B4 You're Gonna
Play Knight back to D1 and now after A5
it seems like black uh won a lot of a
lot of squares here but now Knight to C4
and all of a sudden it's not as clear
the A5 Pawn is weak the Knight can come
to B6 uh it's not um not very pleasant
for black but again I think that's why
uh another book played Rook H to D1 he's
not playing to win this he's playing not
to lose this so Rook H to D1 Now Pawn to
H4 a very important move as you'll see
later on in the game with Knight to G4
and now Knights the C6 attacks The Rook
on D4 Rook 4 to D2 and now Rook the H5
Jordan goes for the G5 pawn and now Pawn
to E5 this is a very very tricky move uh
where if you actually capture an E5 you
can just resign if you capture an E5
then Knight captures and now everything
is hanging the Knight on c67 hanging
with check uh the Knight cannot move
because the Rook is hanging also the
rook and H5 is attacked there's just not
nothing you can do here so uh the end
okay let's say root captures on D2 if
you guys are interested Knight
characters and G6 will come with check
after King F7 you pick up the Rook now
threaten all sorts of nasty discoveries
Rook capture Sandy one with check King
captures and now once you get the king
out of the way Knight captain for Europe
two Pawns in a in a better position
white will win this easily so instead D5
by Jordan and now Knight to E4 again I
made possible
uh as you you can't really play D
captures on e4 if you play D captures on
E for now uh yes The Rook here is
defended twice but still it's gonna be
very very tricky for example Rook
captures Knight captures now Knight to
F6 uh it's a very very unpleasant
position for black if Rook captures uh
on G5 then Rook the D7 is an option all
of a sudden King the Fate has to be
played now Rook chapter 78 with Chair
King goes uh here now you're gonna
capture on G8 and so on your position
just falls apart so instead after Knight
the E4 with Bishop the C8 very nicely uh
played by Jordan and now Knight G2 F6
Knight G2 F2 might be yeah even a a bit
more solid but Knight G2 F6 is what he
goes for attacks The Rook on H5 Rook to
a trade and now Knight captures ng8 with
check Rook D captress and G8 and now
Knight to F6 so another big gets a
beautiful Knight on F6 but the problem
is if this Knight has nothing to do here
then the E5 engine 5 Pawn are just
long-term weaknesses so Rook to d8 and
now Rook to E1 we have pawned the H3
here uh it could it could have gone uh
very differently if for example Jordan
played Knight captures on E5 here
um uh here another week is saying that
you can't really capture because I have
all sorts of nasty discoveries uh the
problem is if Knight captures there's no
good Discovery you can make
uh problem is a move like Bishop
captures and B5 uh can be met with the
spectacular Ponte H3 this is what I
meant by H4 will be very very useful and
now you can't really capture because you
give up the F3 Square this will come
with an attack on the Rooks and if the
bishop goes back as your Bishop now is
hanging here uh you will just play Pawn
to H2 now threatening H1 and now the
Rook will have to block the Knight just
nicely uh survives here you go Knight F7
you go after the G5 pawn and black is
just much better yeah but okay after
Rook D1 uh Jordan first played H3 he
does it with a bit of a different move
order the problem is now you can capture
on H3 so G captures an H3 Rook captures
and now Bishop G4 attacks The Rook Rook
H4 puts pressure on the bishop and now
Pawn to B3 uh we have Rook Dita h8 uh
doubling up on the H file uh also B4 it
looks very nice just controls A3 and C3
that keeps that white king out of
escaping anywhere but okay Rook detail
controlling the H file completely King
the B2 and now Rook the H2 offering a
Trader Rooks and now Rook e to E2 we
have real characters Rook captures and
now Pawn to A5 we have Pawn to A3 and
the bishop to A6 now preparing to do
some discoveries on The Rook here so
Rook to E1 and now Pawn to B4 we have A4
another very happy with closing the
position uh but now Knight to d8 and
this is what I meant by if this isn't
really doing anything uh to Black then
E5 and G5 are just um uh long-term
weaknesses the Knight is coming to F7
and you will not be able to defend both
so here Bishop to E2 offering a trade of
Bishops but uh Jordan very very happily
accepts this bishop captures Rook
captures and Knight to F7 and now you
are losing a pawn you cannot prevent
that so Pawn to C3 we have captures
captures and now Knight captures on G5
Pawn to B 4
another book also wants to create a past
Pawn but now Rook H3 check forcing the
white king away from the pawns with King
to B2 now eight captures on B4 and all
of a sudden uh Jordan is just up two
pawns and another back is in a
completely uh lost position uh we have
rooked the C2 now comes Knight to F3 and
now Knight the G for defending the pawn
uh but here really anything wins you can
just attack the Knight and then pick up
the pawn or you can play it the way
Jordan played Knight to D4 go after the
Rook Rook the C8 but now Rook the B3
with check and you will win the final
Pawn as well we have King to A2 Rook to
A3 check King to B2 Rook captures an A4
we have Knight to F6 now uh and here
just Pawn to B3 and he was in this
position animal 49 that Northern
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here he is down three
pawns with zero counter Play There is
absolutely nothing you can do here once
you give one check but after that King
38 it's a game over rookie to check then
you move the Rook then you advance the
pawn uh it's a game over in in a mere
few moves uh so uh truly a shame for for
another Rebecca dusatrov who played
pretty much the tournament of his life
uh going into the final round
of such an elite tournament one of the
strongest if if not the strongest
tournaments of the year uh maybe only
alireza is missing from from the top 10
but uh I mean absolutely incredible and
now losing in the final round uh still
meant that he could win first place but
Anish won that game against Rapport
we've seen how it happened and that
means Anish wins at the tournament Anish
wins it all and these are the final
standings if you guys are interested so
let me just uh sorry about that those
are the previous standings
uh I have them somewhere here nope I
don't have them here sorry about that
uh sometimes I save stuff in a in a
different folder than I uh that I'm
supposed to uh
weird weird computer there we go uh
these are the the final standings of the
of the 2023 uh Tata steel Masters
Edition so on each giving ones that wins
the tournament with eight and a half
points out of 13 uh which is uh not that
great he he uh he he used to have even
more points in data still but uh yeah uh
you know other people had even more
points so he he didn't win uh but yeah
now he wins it with eight and a half out
of 13 uh followed by another Beck and
Magnus uh sharing second place with
eight out of 13. then seven and a half
out of 13 Wesley so with seven Fabiano
Corona and Parham maxulu six and a half
Lebon Arun and Richard rapport with six
we have pregnant and Northern Farm
Forest after winning this game in this
spectacular fashion with five and a half
World Championship challenge or dingler
and go cash uh with five uh Vincent
kymer and in last place uh Arjun ergasi
not having the best tournament he
dropped some 21 points in this
tournament so he's still 2700 he's like
2701. uh after this but yeah absolutely
incredible in londerbeck who came into
the tournament with 27-13 uh will finish
on some 27 I believe 31 or 32 if he won
this game it could be like over over
27.40 uh but I mean you you can't win
them all but yeah what a what a great
Victory by Jordan like I said uh there
were many moves that I believe
neuterberg would have played it
differently if this wasn't uh such an
important game I think he just wanted to
win the tournament and then he didn't
play like he would usually Play Because
Notre back is uh I mean you you will you
will not see a greater fighter than
another back he is in such top form in
such great shape he will he will fight
you for eight hours you know he will
play a queen and pawn end game against
Magnus Carlsen for hours just uh to
squeeze out a win like we've seen I mean
this man can truly do everything but
here I just feel that uh he was
satisfied with the draw uh he just
didn't want to lose that's the best uh I
have to explain this game but also your
Jordan just played a a brilliant game
just pushing that H Pawn very sneaky
stuff and then I mean good things um
good things happened uh so yeah that's
the game I hope you guys enjoyed it uh
well we're probably gonna check another
one you guys have been requesting the
Magnus Arjun game so we're gonna check
up on that as well uh I would like to uh
thank Alaska Friends book called
revision reptiles YouTube Sasha Butler
and Tara Scorpio for your contribution
to my channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you all
for watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions uh and whatever else happens
in the Chess World so thank you all I
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day and once again huge
congratulations to Anish for winning the
Tata steel Masters 2023 see you soon